merci alors d'abord je vais vous
rassurer il ya beaucoup de parcs
il ya beaucoup de provinciaux à la
tribune guillaume pelletier valérie deux
bords
guillaume larrivé votre serviteur
isabelle le callennec j'en passe merci
pour
merci pour vos remarques vos convictions
un mot sur la primaire le parti
nous avons décidé collectivement de
l'organisation d'une primaire
nous sommes en train de travailler à
fixer ces règles et je salue thierry
solère qui préside le comité
d'organisation tous à placer sur une
sous l'autre une haute autorité la
primaire l'objectif c'est de rassembler
le maximum d'électeurs de la droite et
du centre
la primaire c'est novembre le parti
sa mission c'est de porter un projet
politique c'est de faire débattre ses
militants c'est l'esprit de la carte que
vous avez prises dès que vous avez
prises dans vos fédérations et bien
c'est l'idée de ce conseil national
donc il y a un temps pour la primaire il
ya un temps pour l'émulation entre les
candidats et il ya un temps pour le
débat interne pour l'élaboration du
projet du parti qui est nécessaire